a is free any man who must say I am the
king is no true king
B is for but neither God's nor men will
ever compel me to let you turn Casterly
Rock into your whorehouse C is Burke can
you read D is furred do you think you'll
be the first person dragged into a Sept
to be married against her will
e is for eat f is for Phillip lecherous
little stump G is for grand maester
perhaps some essence of nightshade to
help him sleep I'm not tired
H is first I is furred I wanted to carry
you into the sea and let the waves wash
you away instead I'll let you live
because you're a Lannister J is for
jugglers and singers require applause
you are a Lannister k is for keep it one
hundred man were no family needs all the
help he can get L is for Lannister's
don't act like fools M is from the
cupbearer can read better than you M is
for another word oh it's for old old P
is for people who spend their money on
this sort of nonsense tend not to have
it for long q is for R he's poor Robert
had me funding him Wars what a gold
backup Tiffany of S is for silence
silence
silence T eSports a lion doesn't concern
himself with the opinions of the Sheep
U is for it used to Pat me on the back a
lot V is from where W is we could
arrange to have you carried them X is 4
y is 4 it still fertile you need to
marry again and breed I am Queen Regent
not some broodmare daughter you will do
as I command and you will marry Loras
Tyrell C is 4
[Music]